[Musique]
d'après les enquêtes internationales
pisa réaliser en 2015 un quart des
élèves français est en difficulté cette
étude se fait tous les trois ans je suis
venu vous raconter ce soir une histoire
c'est l'histoire d'une petite fille qui
va à l'école et qui ne se sent pas sa
place qui ne prend pas le sens de la du
cursus scolaire qui ne comprend pas ce
quoi servent les mathématiques la poésie
bref qui est en mal de vivre un mal être
et qui un moment donné s'aperçoit que
son reflet dans l'eau dans les yeux de
ses parents de ses instituteurs de ses
camarades à l'école
nous lui renvoie qu'une image de
médiocrité ce qui la remplit de
tristesse cet enfant ne trouve pas sa
place c'est ce qu'on appelle ici
en tous les cas en france un enfant un
échec scolaire qui aujourd'hui peut
avoir traversé ce type de souffrance ou
être qualifiée d'échec scolaire
j'en vois qui en a c'est bien messieurs
dames courageux salveo la lumière aller
et dieu ritter qui qui qui auront louis
joly en fait ceux qui aujourd'hui
arrivent à vivre ceux ci en tas qui ont
vécu cette situation laïque il y avait
le doigt sont déjà en phase déjà de
guérison ça veut dire qu'ils ont ils
sont passés par dessus
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait dans
ces deux photos et bien c'est une vie
parce que cette petite fille c'est moi
voilà vous avez le premier tronçon de ma
vie ce qui s'est passé d'un j'ai appris
à prendre
j'ai appris à vivre j'ai appris à
travailler à concevoir à modéliser à
construire mais aussi à réussir parce
que si on arrive à faire ce genre de
choses et c'est pas réservé qu'à une
forme d'élite s'est réservé à ceux qui
veulent malheureusement vouloir s'en
sortir et faire ce qu'il a à faire
après cette réussite dit social on va
dire parce que pour moi c'était pas ma
réussite était la réussite codifié
socialement je me suis retrouvée au bout
de quelques années à me dire mais
impossible avec ma dyslexie avec ma
souffrance avec mes problèmes pour me
retenir mais tables de multiplication
que je ne sais toujours pas faux pas le
raconter aux enfants parce que sinon ça
le fait pas comment comment je vais
arriver jeu s'arrête là comment mon
chemin se dit aujourd'hui je me retrouve
j'ai fait de l'argent j'ai maintenu des
familles mais finalement qu'est ce que
je fais de mon savoir de ma connaissance
toutes ces années passées à étudier et
je me suis dit il ya quelque chose que
je n'ai pas saisi dans ce chemin en tous
les cas pour moi ce n'était pas logique
ni rationnel dont je suis parti en quête
du graal j'ai commencé à faire des
recherches sur l'apprentissage sur toute
la partie les neurosciences sûr
les multi intelligence sur qu'est-ce
qu'on a pris d'autres sur l'hypnose jeu
quand je faisais les choses je les
faisais jusqu'au bout je vais aller
passer jusqu'à mont duplan
d'hypnothérapie experts spécialisés dans
les dix on sait jamais pourquoi parce
que j'estime qu'un enfant qui est 10e
devient un adulte 10 est certain qu'on
n'aura pas compris ça on n'aura pas donc
pendant plus de dix ans je fais des
recherches autour du concept apprendre à
apprendre et je me suis dit que c'était
peut-être dans cette conférence le
moment de vous faire partager
en tous les cas ce qui m'a paru
significatif ce qui m'a paru sympa etc
dans tous les cas de vous l'exprimer
clairement le premier point que je
voulais partager avec vous c'est
l'orphelin quand le régime de ceausescu
tombée il ya quelques années je sais pas
si certaines familles personnes se
souviennent encore de ces photos qui ont
défilé sur nos écrans nous étions pour
certains très très enfants dans tous les
cas pour je ne sais pas mais moi j'étais
très très petit
voilà en fait ces enfants on les a on a
su qu'ils avaient passé vingt qu'ils
avaient passé de 3 ans qu'à 35 ans pour
certains enfermé jour et nuit du noir
matin enfin bon c'est un petit peu
compliqué pour eux mêmes beaucoup mais à
la suite de ça on a remplacé une partie
de ses enfants dans des familles qui ont
été adoptées et d'autres parties de
notre parti on les a placés vous a
continué à les maintenir dans son
orphelinat 10 de ce nom d'accord ses
enfants sont partis du même postulat 1
avec le même numéro de qi à on va dire
pour tous et à l'arrivée on s'est rendu
compte que quinze ans plus tard les
enfants qui étaient en orphelinat et et
avait entre 70 et 80 de qi et ceux qui
étaient dans une famille avait entre 80
et 90 ce que nous démontre cette étude
tout simplement que quand on est entouré
d'amour ou en tous les cas quand on a
une stabilité émotionnelle
on est plus enclin à pouvoir mieux
apprendre
en tous les cas et à pouvoir se dire que
finalement ben on est entouré de quelque
chose en tous les cas un facteur le
deuxième la deuxième étude que je
voudrais vous faire partager c'est celle
que j'ai découvert où j'ai découvert
d'ailleurs le ted
c'était sur les multi intelligence donc
les multis intelligent
j'ai découvert ça donc lord hunt aide
est là quand j'ai vu ça ça a été une
révélation pour moi je dis mais comment
ça on est tous intelligents mais d'où
sort ce type au fabuleux jeu le like moi
qui toute mon enfance mme avaient tagué
en me disant que finalement je ne ferai
rien de ma vie un que je n'étais pas
doué et que le seul métier je pouvais
faire et dieu merci heureusement qu'il
ya des coiffeuses mecs était coiffeuse
ou femme de ménage est encore une fois
merci des femmes de ménage d'accord
puisque ma destinée était déjà tout
tracé
l'autorité on avait décidé comme ça
l'autorité avait décidé que maïté qu'un
panel était pas bonne à l'école avec sa
dyslexie devait partir dans un cursus
court très bien à l'époque je vous
rappelle le contexte
ma mère dit ok quant à faire ça
heureusement que ma peau mais ramadi on
va juste organiser autrement au lieu dit
oui à la maîtresse mais ça va bien se
passer
on va faire tomber et là quand je
découvre les multis intelligent je me
rends compte que en fait il y a d'après
la théorie doha garner qui t'arrive 1,83
il ya neuf aujourd'hui forme
d'intelligence sur lesquels nous avons
tous ces intelligences d'accord la seule
chose c'est que nous allons simuler plus
d'intelligence que d'autres et tous se
répartit différemment et en général on
les compare 3 ça veut dire qu'on a trois
intelligence qui sont beaucoup plus
stimulée que que la normale il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui la l'éducation
nationale le parc est la logique aux
mathématiques et la littéraire le reste
des intelligences font que ça n'existe
pas on ne peut pas s'adapter à tout le
monde
alors imaginez des enfants des adultes
qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas été stimulé
par ce type d'intelligence et gars qui
ont leur expliquer gentiment ben faut y
aller
là maintenant il ya les rouges et les
bleus les rouges chez des intelligents
et les bleus c'est les traiterait moins
intelligente elle avoue passer sur le
côté gauche est plus à les faire ce que
vous voulez et tout ça juste parce qu'à
un moment donné on ne sait pas nous
parler avec les intelligences qui vend
bien c'est pathétique
oui oui mais tout en sachant
qu'aujourd'hui ces intelligences sur les
9 8 sont reconnus en actions cérébrale
sous irm et scanner
seule une la nature alice n'est pas
reconnu donc ça serait linverse je
comprendrais mais je trouve un peu
dommage que finalement ce type de test
vous allez retrouver sur internet
surtout n'hésitez pas prenez en photo
vous allez trouver des tests
en fait ça fait les faire à vos enfants
parce que c'est c'est juste un moment
donné des révélations pour certaines
personnes et certains enfants encore
aujourd'hui dans ma quête des
neurosciences puisque comme je suis à un
moment donné on est obligé d'y arriver
un sens on va te dire ce tir pensée très
bien les multi intelligence pour ça et
puis quand on commence à sortir le fil
de la pelote
on est obligé d'arriver au chapitre des
neurosciences et les neurosciences j'ai
trouvé le système d'activation
réticulaire alors je vais essayer de
vous en faire une traduction simple et
courte parce que c'est un peu compliqué
mais vous allez vite comprendre vous
allez vite comprendre comment les tous
atteints et que l'on a tous bien notre
star le sar est là donc c'est une
structure nerveux ça c'est pour
commencer mais il a la faculté de
prendre une information du conscient la
filtrer parce qu'à un moment donné ils
méritent ils pensent que c'est
nécessaire de vous la montrer
et il la ramène dans le subconscient
pour faire ça il se sert et icontrol
l'éveil et la tension
bien sûr vous me direz 1 mais un gentil
elle mais après c'est un peu l'air un
peu compliqué mais vous allez vite voir
ça peut se simplifier
si il a la capacité de prendre du
subconscient de le ramener l'inconscient
quand nous le matin on lui dit
aujourd'hui je vais passer une journée
de pas simple d'accord j'ai décidé
qu'aujourd'hui je passais une journée
voilà qui était passant pas le sort lui
un moment donné comme la nature a
horreur du vide notre cerveau aussi
voilà qu'est ce qui va faire il va
prendre un moment donné il a égrainé lui
sa mission alors moi j'aime bien ça
mais savoir avoir raison lui colle aussi
parfaitement
ça veut dire que lui va savoir un moment
donné qu'il faut remplir il faut remplir
et vous donner raison parce que lui ont
bien dit je vais passer une journée
pas sympa et bien tout ce qui va se
passer dans cette journée va cadencé et
lui il va faire le tri et vous ramener
que tout ce qui est pas sympa parce que
lui il est fidèle
il est tellement fidèle qu'il est
toujours avec nous et quand je dis fidel
fidel et quand on lui dit je veux passer
une journée de merde où une journée
sympa et bien lui il prend il est aux
ordres et il prend il vous fait ça
correctement
et tiré au cordeau je vous explique si
moi je décide avant de venir de rentrée
en disant ben voila je vais faire une
conférence à tout casser mon regard
moi personnellement ne va se poser que
sur des gens qui vont me regarder qui
vont être attentionné qui vont me
sourire et qui vont me donner une
réception dont j'ai besoin pour faire
une belle conférence l'éclairage va être
fantastique et la moquette dans le monde
peut pas totale si je décide en rentrant
je veux dire tais je fais une conférence
mais ça va être compliqué là tout va ce
qu'audi fille en fonction ça veut dire
que mon regard va se poser sur des gens
qui font la tête qui s'endorment etc etc
etc
pour illustrer la dernière fois ce
chapitre du sart c'est très simple vous
avez tous vécu un moment donné vous êtes
allé acheter une voiture et peut-être
dans une concession et en achetant cette
voiture en sortant mais je vois bien un
dans la baie temps pour bien content et
tout est là on se rend compte qu il a
acheté la même mais la même alors pas la
même couleur peut-être pas la même
finition mais en tout état de cause on
se retrouve à voir dans les dix jours
qui suivent le même véhicule que nous
avons achetés pourquoi parce qu
obligatoirement votre sar va vous
rassurer dans votre achat
c'est son job c'est son job de vous dit
tu vois tu as fait un bon achat tout le
monde a acheté cette voiture
elle avait vu on a besoin de personnel
toussaint on se dit je vais aller
acheter ma caisse givet est l'atout pour
tout ça on est ok je voulais vous
partager aussi l'histoire des croyances
et vous allez voir alain lien avec le
soir qui est assez sympathique
l'histoire des croyants c'est quoi c'est
en général me déposer dans notre cerveau
par l'autorité alors l'autorité ben
c'est un instituteur une paire à faire
un père une mère voilà quelques la
famille même tous les cas quelqu'un que
nous avons décidé que ce type là où
cette personne n'a été plus intelligente
que nous qu'elle avait plus de pouvoirs
et qu'à un moment donné on s'est dit
pour x raisons fondées ou pas qu'elle
avait plus de raisonnement pour prendre
les décisions qui nous incombe est donc
on se retrouve avec des gens quelques
coups par des pauses des croyances alors
ça se fait un de génération en
génération ça peut se faire
s'il ya membres inconsciemment on peut
retrouver tous les cas de figure mais en
tout état de cause il y a juste une
réflexion - qui m'a amené dans ce temps
là c'est que on se retrouve par exemple
socialement un enfant qui va aux
primaires à l'école dire qu'il aime sa
maîtresse et qu'il aime son école tout
va bien en sixième trouvez moi un enfant
boutonneux qui va vous expliquer qu'il
adore aller à l'école et qu'il adore sa
maîtresse et ben non
pourquoi parce qu'il ya là le leader ou
la leadeuse de l'école qui a dit à un
moment donné c'est tellement fun et
c'est tellement mauvais d'aller à
l'école que c'est nul
et à un moment donné cette croyance a
été déposée au même titre que ces gens
là bas ces gamins-là ils ont grandi ça
veut dire nous aujourd'hui sont en poste
et quelque part si le premier le premier
on va dire job que l'on a pris ou le
dernier mais avec quelqu'un qui rentre
et que l'on connaissait qui pourrait
avoir autorité à un moment donné se met
chez nous l'idée que de la boîte dans
laquelle nous travaillons que le patron
n'était pas celui que l'on devrait
mériter ou quoi que ce soit nous nous
retrouvons encore une fois avec des
croyances et cette croyance fait qu'à un
moment donné nous n'aimons pas le
travail que nous faisons nous n'aimons
pas la boîte dans laquelle nous allons
travailler et ça c'est dommage parce que
ça c'est encore le sar qui codifie ça
veut dire qu'à un moment donné son le
sar du type le manager ou le collègue
est arrivé vous a dit c'est une boîte de
mer n'essayez pas ensuite le dis
sincèrement là on monte dès que je peux
je me casse 1 et là vous des pires lui
il est là depuis longtemps
je lui ai laissé autorités et les venues
déposer dans mon cerveau sa croyance
alors que quelque part lui ne le fait
pas inconsciemment
malheureusement dans ce ce peace l'âge
de comportement il y a une liaison un
français qui se fait avec
l'apprentissage ça veut dire que quand
on est enfant et quand on est un adulte
en travaillant on a besoin d'apprendre
tous les jours des nouvelles tâches
nouvelles choses et ça on sait plus les
faire puisque obligatoirement on a fermé
on accroît zone et on a décidé qu'à un
moment donné on n'aimait plus et si on
n'aime pas on sait pas à prendre
pourquoi parce qu'en effet le petit qui
lui est en primaire comme il aime sa
maîtresse
que ce soit pour lui faire plaisir ou se
faire plaisir à un moment donné il va y
aller à partir de là quand on a vu
terminer toutes ces recherches
on s'est retrouvé à monter un comité
pédagogique
à l'intérieur on a retrouvé mon avec ma
dyslexie et mon parcours on a retrouvé
de docteur en neurosciences on a
retrouvé des personnes qui tiennent la
pédagogie et on a fait le constat au
bout de quelques mois de quelque chose
qui était quand même émerveillement pour
nous en tous les cas pour moi c'est que
nous étions tous dans la pédagogie les
enfants quand ils vont à l'école on est
tous dans la pédagogie
le manager quand il apprend à son
employé s'il est dans la pédagogie
alors on est tous dans la pédagogie et
si juste trois minutes on se poser la
question est ce qu'en termes de
réception je peux être le meilleur
pédagogue mais si ça rentre pas dans
l'individu dans le sujet ça rentrera
jamais je peux être même s'il faut faire
la roue s'ils le font ça ça a été le
plus compliqué à mettre en place et
c'est comme ça qu'on a développé une
méthode qui s'appelle un euro à 6 me qui
aujourd'hui donne cette fois plus de
rétention de formation mais qui en plus
de ça permet de rentrer à l'intérieur ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que apprendre c'est bien quand on
n'a pas tout un tas de croyances qui
vont bien mais en tout état de cause on
se retrouve avec une naissance il n'est
sans skier nous comment je réceptionne
cette foutue compétences et qu'est ce
que je vais en faire un moment donné
alors face à ce monde qui change
moi je voudrais juste partage et de
petites choses trois exactement
imaginez un monde où nous parents grands
parents et le reste de la famille
nous déposons dans le cerveau de nos
enfants ou des plus petits de nos neveux
et cette erreur d'autres enfants que
nous pourrions voir des petites graines
en disant mais toi tu sais quoi
tu sais faire ça merveilleusement bien
tu as du talent pour faire cette passe
est actée activité là un moment donné on
va savoir leur insuffler et même si dans
ce jardin de compétence la graine ne va
pas germé et fleurir dans les six mois
qui viennent dans cinq ans dans dix ans
ou dans 20 ans quelqu'un par mopar une
phrase viendra rosé cette graine et s'en
fera un beau jardin de compétence ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose dans ce
monde où nous devons
commencé à changer pour que les choses
changent ça veut dire que chaque jour
qui passe pouvoir faire le 1 tous les
cas autour de nous ce qu'on n'a pas eu
la chance d'avoir le deuxième point
c'est idéalement imaginé en septembre de
l'année prochaine à la rentrée on a une
heure pour nos enfants on appelle ça la
la matière du futur oui la matière du
futur et qu'est ce qu'on fait dans cette
matière le du lundi de 10h à 11h et ben
en fait on va nous expliquer paix qu'en
fait vous êtes boutonneux vous êtes
adolescents que vous souffrez mais vous
souffrez parce que finalement vous
n'avez pas le même format d'amour avec
votre avec vos parents voilà et que vous
êtes en conflit avec eux parce que vous
avez l'impression ou en tous les cas
vous avez le sentiment de ne pas être
aimée alors qu'ils vous aiment sauf que
dans les cinq formes d'amour ça ne colle
pas ça veut dire aussi pourquoi on a des
blessures les blessures qui nous
empêchent d'être soi-même en fait tout
ce genre de choses qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui malheureusement dans ce
grand vase du développement personnel
mais qui sont une codification des
outils pour pouvoir fonctionner et ça je
pense que ça serait important
et le troisième point je dirais que si
dans mes rêves les plus fous serait que
tout le monde puisse être free lance
demain matin ça veut dire travailler
dans son chemin de vie faire que ce
qu'il a envie
en tous les cas quand j ce faire ce
qu'il a envie travailler dans sa passion
ça voudrait dire que ça éviterait à des
jobs et aujourd'hui on a 20 % on
s'amusait 80% on se fait suer dans notre
boulot parce qu'on se dit ben ouais mais
bon je suis obligé une lettre de mission
genesis a à faire ça pour moi serez
aussi une facilité et un confort de vie
dans le sens où tous les gens pourraient
travailler dans leur chemin de vie dans
le plaisir et exceller et augmenter
leurs talents leurs compétences et en
fabriquer de nouveaux ça ça serait une
bonne chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]